[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
gange était des territoires voici les
titres de l'actualité
tout d'abord nous nous rendrons à nice
où a eu lieu cette attaque mortelle au
couteau dans la basilique notre dame de
l'assomption
nous ferons le point sur place avec tout
ce que l'on peut connaître de cette
situation le tour de vis de l'état face
à la crise sanitaire
la france se confirme face à l'ampleur
du nombre de cas de co vide 19
évidemment un noël sans marcher avec les
conséquences de toutes ces mesures
ces grandes manifestations qui rythment
la vie de nos territoires sont
pratiquement tout annuler enfin tous à
l'électrique nous irons à bordeaux où
les vieilles voitures diesel ou essence
sont transformés en véhicules 100%
électriques
cela s'appelle le retrofit voilà nous
nous rendons à nice comme je vous le
disais dans les titres pour faire le
point sur cet attentat mortel qui a eu
lieu dans la cathédrale notre dame de
l'assomption
bonjour denis carot vous êtes le
directeur des rédactions du groupe nice
matin merci d'être avec nous en duplex
de nice pouvez vous nous faire le point
sur l'enquêté
après cet attentat donc qui a eu lieu
dans la basilique notre dame de
l'assomption à nice bat cyril le profil
du terroriste a été déterminé assez vite
un des des jeudis soirs on sait qu'il
s'agit d'un tunisien âgé de 21 ans qui
est rentré en france par l'italie à la
fin du mois de septembre en provenance
de lampedusa ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
ce qu'il a fait entre le 20 septembre et
jeudi avant l'attentât
les caméras de vidéosurveillance de nghi
son
on démontre et qu'il était arrivé à la
gare de nice jeudi matin avec une zone
de flou assez étrange il restait une
heure et demie à la gare on ne sait pas
ce qu'il a fait pendant sept 7h30 et il
s'est ensuite rendu à la basilique
notre-dame où il est resté visiblement
dans l'ombre pendant quelques minutes
avant d'attaquer ses victimes qui ont
été égorgés au sein même de
de la basilique en plein coeur de nice
au début de la semaine le directeur
général de la police nationale a appelé
à la vigilance
indiquant dans un télégramme adressé aux
directions des services centraux que la
france est la cible d'une menace
terroriste élevée et constante
oui syrie on sait qu' il y avait un
contexte depuis depuis quelques quelques
jours il y à cette alerte mais qui ne
concernait pas plus ni ce que les autres
villes de france et on sait que depuis
notamment l' attaque devant les anciens
locaux de charlie hebdo depuis
l'assassinât à conflans sainte honorine
d'une du professeur samuel pâtit il y
avait des risques partout sur le
territoire
mais d'une certaine manière à nice qui
est encore tellement bouleversée
traumatisé par l'attentât du 14 juillet
2016 on ne voulait pas croire que c'est
cette tragédie pouvait se répéter et que
la folie terroristes islamistes pouvait
à nouveau frappé en plein coeur de nice
voilà merci denis carot je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur des rédactions de
nice-matin vous intervenir duplex de
nice voilà nous poursuivons avec les
réactions après le nouveau confinement
annoncé par le président de la
république
les écoles vont rester ouvertes mais les
commerces fermeront donc quant au monde
du spectacle déjà durement touchée c'est
un nouveau coup dur pour lui
regardez les réactions avec ce reportage
de nos confrères de 8 mont blanc tourné
sur la scène nationale d'annecy
un peu sonnés mais où travaillent au
lendemain de la noce dur confinement
artistes et techniciens sont sur scène
trois compagnies devaient ouvrir la
nouvelle saison la semaine prochaine à
bonlieu les représentations et le public
attendront dans la salle de création la
compagnie l'art de vivre en profitera
pour réaliser le film du spectacle nous
on a créé ce spectacle au moins 2 au
mois de mars
on devait venir jouer ici ça a été
reporté on arrive là et encore une fois
on peut pas jouer voilà c'était
inimaginable que tout s'arrête de toute
façon salvador garcia prend la
température du jour de scène en scène
dans la petite salle le montage de la
création de fannie car en caux a
commencé on à arriver
hier soir et on s'est dit de toute façon
quoique ce soit qui se passe il faut il
faut qu'on soit là quoi même si même si
on doit repartir tout de suite mais on
savait pas mais c'est super important
d'être là et du coup là de pouvoir
monter pouvoir continuer à répéter dans
la grande salle aussi les équipes sont
concentrées très attendu la dernière
création du collectif mxm prend forme
la mouette de tchekhov revisité attendra
elle aussi pour se révéler à son public
c'est peut-être intéressant aussi de se
dire que le théâtre n'est pas comme une
représentation
c'est un lieu aussi on transmet on
travaille comme tout artisan comme tout
ouvrier et que sa roue mais aussi les
choses je pense au coeur du métier c'est
qu'est ce que nous faisons à quelle
légitimité nous avons aujourd'hui de
continuer de travailler
moi je n'ai pas peur comme dirait
tchekhov de la vie donc il faut y aller
il faut travailler il faut mais
forcément ça va modifier pour moi et ça
doit considérablement de modifier notre
façon de travailler et le regard qu'on
va porter sur sur les sujets qu'on
aborde quoi le ministère de la culture
s'est engagé à soutenir le spectacle
vivant à hauteur de 85 millions d'euros
il ya une dizaine de jours reste
l'incertitude de la réouverture se fait
beaucoup mais ça fait beaucoup pour les
restaurateurs ça fait beaucoup pour les
entreprises savaient beaucoup pour
beaucoup beaucoup de secteurs donc on
n'est pas les seuls
je crois que de toute façon qui soit
totalement incongru de se plaint de
cette situation là qui touche tout le
monde pourrait très bien imaginer que si
l'état sont fermés jusqu'à au moins de
mars mais qu'on peut continuer à
travailler on puisse produire d'autres
d'autres pièces qui pourraient être
prêtes
cet été ou à la rentrée alors qu'elle
devait distribuer abonnement éthique et
la billetterie accueilli bien le public
ce jeudi
mais pour des remboursements ils ont
déjà commencé écoutons à présent l'appel
à l'aide des maires de la loire face à
l'ampleur du nombre de cas de co vide et
du manque de soignants dans la région
les mers du sud du département notamment
demandent l'assistance sanitaire de
l'armée comme cela avait été le cas en
avril dernier à mu
nous tous les détails avec ce reportage
de nos confrères de tele7 télé loire 7
sur place c'est un appel qui a eu de
l'écho ce week end dans une lettre
adressée mercredi dernier à la préfète
de la loire 21 maires de la vallée du
gier on demandait que soit envoyé est
des moyens sanitaires militaire
autrement dit l'installation à d'un
hôpital militaire comme ce qui avait été
le cas à mulhouse au printemps dernier
au plus fort de la première vague une
demande formulée à l'unanimité des élus
quels que soient leur famille politique
et qui s'appuie notamment sur la courbe
d'évolution de l'épidémie et le fait que
plusieurs communes comme la grand croix
est un taux d'incidence supérieur à 1000
cas positifs pour 100000 habitants des
tests pcr sens de son positif à plus de
30%
donc la situation est grave voire
dramatique dans la vallée du gier
particulièrement à la grand croix
le nombre d'hospitalisations ne cesse de
monter de grimper en flèche et face à ça
nous avons du personnel qui est épuisée
depuis le mois de mars avec un manque de
moyens terrible et nous demandons donc
le maximum de moyens à l'état car en
quelques jours le nombre de malades
qu'ovide hospitalisé à saint chamond est
passé de 50 à 130
suffisant pour que les autorités tendre
une oreille attentive à la demande des
maires du gier la réponse à ce jour
c'est pourquoi pas c'est pourquoi pas je
crois que tout le monde souhaite être
constructif
alors est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit à
saint chamond où je le rappelle nous
n'avons pas de réanimation
nos patients partent ensuite sur
saint-etienne où il a peut-être un
hôpital militaire pourrait à terme être
plus pertinent puisque l'hôpital
militaire une louche par exemple proposé
de la réanimation et des mères
interloqué par les propos de la députée
de la majorité valeria formule tyan et
qui regrettait que des manifestations
et quand même été organisés cet été
c'est vrai que nous sommes un certain
nombre de maires à être vraiment très
attristé par cette démarche par ses
propos au mépris de tout le travail des
mères qui sont eux en première ligne
rappelons quand même que cet été nous
étions période de déconfinement que les
élus ont assumé cela avec un minimum
effectivement de vie sociale et de vie
économique mais nous avons respecté
scrupuleusement ce que l'état nous
proposait un rendez vous lors a en tout
cas été fixé en préfecture ce mardi
après midi à quatorze heures trente en
compagnie de l'aérés
pour définir les meilleurs moyens pour
aider les soignants de la vallée du gier
voilà je vous le disais dans les titres
c'est une tradition qui malheureusement
ne pourra pas avoir lieu cette année en
france en raison de la crise sanitaire
les marchés de noël qui attire de très
nombreux visiteurs ne pourront pas avoir
lu en france c'est le cas dans les hauts
de france à amiens où cette décision du
maire a été accueillie avec tristesse
comme le montre ce témoignage de nos
confrères de wéo la chaîne de la voix du
nord sur place il n'aura pas fait
exception comme ses voisins lillois
arrageois ou encore strasbourgeois
le marché de noël amiénois est annulé la
crise sanitaire aurait eu raison de la
23e édition de l'événement et de ses
cent trente chalets installés dans le
centre ville et dans les rues d'amiens
les avis sont partagés quant à la
décision d'annuler le marché et c'est
vrai que le marché noël en moi ça fait
une activité super intéressante à
partager en famille entre amis etc qui
malheureusement de rallier en faute de
conduite quoi même si il ya plus de
monde de toute façon on sait très bien
qu'à noël y aura du monde partout dans
les magasins donc il vaut mieux être à
l'extérieur que dans les magasins
entassent issue raisonnable je vais
ensuite la meilleure décision à faire
c'est pas grave on aura l'année
prochaine dans deux ans dans trois ans
voilà on essaiera d'acheter des cadeaux
chez des ti commerçants plutôt qu'aller
dans les grandes enseignes
en effet chez les commerçants du
centre-ville comme aurélie l'inquiétude
est grande et le manque à gagner est
colossal
c'est le moment qui rattrape tout c'est
le moment qui vous permet de d'entamer
une année suivante sereinement et là bas
c'est le gros point d'interrogation
depuis plusieurs semaines la fédération
des commerçants travailler avec la
mairie et la préfecture a essayé de
trouver des solutions compatibles avec
les mesures sanitaires mais aucune ne
permettait d'organiser l'événement
sereinement qu'on s'est passé comment ça
va ce qu on va se comporter la clientèle
on espère que les gens fréquentent un
peu plus le centre-ville et soit en
affection avec les commerçants parce que
parce que c'est économiquement pour eux
ça va être ça va être vitale
économiquement et touristiquement
parlant c'est une décision très
difficile pour la ville mais finalement
prévisible
force est de constater que ces derniers
jours on a bien vu l'évolution de du
virus qui augmenté de manière
exponentielle
et puis si nous on avait gardé le marché
de noël ici on aurait il au risque
d'avoir effectivement d'aider des
personnes venant de l'extérieur risque
est de nous contaminer ici donc je
pensais que vraiment c'est et c'était
pas très pas très raisonnable les
commerçants et la ville réfléchissent
maintenant à des animations qui pourrait
permettre d'installer tout de même la
magie de noël dans la ville voit la
conséquence aux prises de conscience de
la population
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
vouloir évidemment vous faire vacciner
contre la grippe saisonnière
sauf que les vaccins commençaient à
manquer direction une petite commune du
grand test vous allez voir où on a pu
constater que les pharmaciens sont pris
d'assaut
c'est un reportage signé des équipes de
viavoice sur place donc ça en ce moment
c'est très précieux c'est très très très
précieux ils se font rares en effet les
vaccins contre la grippe peut non
seulement dans cette pharmacie à darné
ou le peu de stock est parti en trois
jours mais aussi partout dans les vosges
et même dans la france entière ont fait
face à une véritable pénurie
les pharmaciens avaient pourtant bien
passer leurs commandes comme d'habitude
en tout début d'année
j'ai passé ma commande au mois de
janvier pour être livrés théoriquement
fin septembre or cette année fin
septembre nous n'avons reçu aucune dose
les doses sont arrivés tardivement au
mois d'octobre et avec grande surprise
nous n'avons eu que la moitié des doses
commandées
les laboratoires paraît-il avait
pourtant anticipé une plus forte demande
cette année est donc produit bien plus
de doses que d'habitude alors plusieurs
questions se posent que sont devenus
tous ces vaccins
comment répondre
à cette forte demande souvent motivée
par la situation sanitaire que l'on
connaît et les pharmacies seront elles
livrer à temps c'est-à-dire avant le
début de l'épidémie annuel aucune
réponse pour le monde je suis déçu parce
que par rapport à la communication
qu'ils ont fait sur le bénéfice d'une
vaccination contre la grippe
surtout cette année pour moi c'est une
première donc et qu'un ami ton pourra
pas être servi
donc je prends on n'a plus rien à donner
aux lots jour d'aujourd'hui
donc nous proposons de garder leur bon
de vaccination puisque ce sont les gens
porteurs d'un bon de vaccination qui
doivent être traitées en priorité et
nous les mettons donc en liste d'attenté
les personnes de plus de 65 ans celles
atteintes de maladies chroniques et les
femmes enceintes notamment sont
prioritaires de son côté le ministère de
la santé a annoncé qu'un million deux
cent mille doses devraient être livrés
d'ici quelques jours
bien sûr l'isère maintenant pour
découvrir une entreprise où les salariés
sont des personnes en situation de
handicap
il fabrique près de 300 masque inclusif
par jour grâce à des plexiglas
transparent ils permettent de voir les
lèvres et la bouche et donc de faciliter
la communication avec les personnes
malentendantes sourdes ou avec des
handicaps cognitifs
un reportage de télégrenoble sur place
regarder un sourire ne coûte rien mais
il crée beaucoup ce proverbe semble
aujourd'hui bien loin de notre actualité
à cause des masques qui cache la moitié
des expressions de nos visages et c'est
d'autant plus vrai pour les personnes
qui lisent sur les lèvres pour pallier
cela aille chirol l'association des
paralysés de france apf s'est lancé dans
la création de masques inclusif par le
biais de plexiglas transparent
il permet d'éviter la discrimination
dont sont victimes les malentendants
depuis l'obligation du port du masque à
la base c'était année sa micra baisse
donc la fondatrice des masques inclusif
et a eu une difficulté pour se faire
entendre dans une pharmacie et de là est
née l'idée du masque inclusif c'était
de permettre de voir les lèvres pour
mieux se faire comprendre que c'est
original du coup c'est des masques à
destination des personnes en situation
de handicap
réalisé par une entreprise adaptée par
des personnes en situation de handicap
dans cet atelier c'est 250 à 300 masque
qui sont produits chaque jour grâce au
travail minutieux des membres de
l'association qui emploie 80 % de
personnes en situation d'handicap une
vingtaine de main sont à l'heure à
l'oeuvre il faudra en moyenne deux
minutes pour créer un masque chez dans
l'étape première étape belge à travers
rassembler les étiquettes avec pvc avec
les tuer c'est trois pièces faut les
rassembler pour première étape de
masques et puis le deuxième étape c'est
leur assemblage de l'ensemble avec le
lui billets et les élastiques
du coup il reste la dernière étape qui
se rassemblent age ii le pvc avec le
tissu et levier et puis on passe à la
dernière étape c'est la finition
contrôle général l emballage la ps a
pour objectif de produire 1000 masques
transparent par jour un moyen dans cette
période de crise sanitaire de redonner
le sourire à tous avec ce confinement
nous partons maintenant loire atlantique
où vous allez le voir ces familles ont
choisi l'instruction à la maison leurs
enfants ne vont pas à l'école c'est les
parents qui leur transmettent les
savoirs fondamentaux
nous allons rencontrer ces familles
grâce aux reportages de nos confrères de
tv nantes sur place regarder voilà
joshua qui a 16 ans tristan 13 ans hier
et à delhi 7 ans et demi trois élèves
pour une même classe en semaine de 9h à
12h la fratrie se retrouvent dans cette
pièce de la maison dédiée à
l'instruction pour les guider leur mère
alice s'est formé à la pédagogie
montessori il ya quelques années j'étais
enceinte venez quand on a pris cette
décision là puisque on souhaitait partir
en bateau on est parti quand tristan
avait une quinzaine de jours et donc je
fais des trois ans on est parti quatre
ans en bateau et quand on est revenu
ça marchait bien comme ça ils avaient 7
et 4 ans ça se passait bien y avait pas
de raison de changer sont libres de
d'explorer je dirais presque ce qui les
intéresse car bien sûr ils ont chacun
leur préférence
joshua veut tout connaître sur le
sommeil à delhi aime beaucoup la
géométrie tristan est presque incollable
sur le tableau périodique des éléments
l'histoire est un peu le français va pas
qu'il faut trop écrire non plus puis par
contre en ce moment j'aime pas trop les
malins si c'est un peu chacun son rythme
mais pas question d'oublier des matières
tout cela est bien encadrée avec la
visite d'un inspecteur d'académie chaque
année joshua passer son brevet l'année
dernière il a donc dû bachoter j'avais
des cours par correspondance du
gouvernement on avait acheté des livres
du programme et fallait que je réussisse
les exercices qui étaient des extras du
brevet des années passées précédente
j'en ai un peu marre à la fin je peux
plus étudiée du tout ce qui me ce qui
m'intéresse c'est vraiment son brevet en
poche
l'aîné a hésité à prendre la route du
lycée avant de renoncer
préférant garder ses après midi pour
faire du sport en peu de temps
finalement on arrive à travailler de
façon plus approfondie des sujets
puisqu'il ya un seul enfant qui
travaille une seule notion dans une
classe de trente c'est je pense très
compliqué de s'adapter à chaque enfant
on a ce choix en france quand on le
prend un choix aujourd'hui remise en
question si la loi sur l'école à la
maison est adoptée les trois enfants
devront s'inscrire dans un établissement
scolaire dès la rentrée prochaine
plus qu'inquiète je suis choqué pour la
plupart des familles en 1 10 98% des
contrôles ont des retours positifs
donc je comprends pas du tout cette
décision les familles se retrouvent tous
les vendredis après midi l'occasion pour
les enfants de jouer ensemble et pour
les parents de parler pédagogie à
présent le projet de loi est au coeur
des discussions
l'association a interpellé les députés
et réfléchit à des actions pour se
garder l'instruction à la maison voici
maintenant de l'initiative d'une
rennaise qui devrait faire parler d'elle
adélaïde a créé un groupe facebook pour
permettre à des femmes de rentrer en
toute sécurité le soir chez elle
celle folk woman rennes a déjà près de
2000 fidèles
regardez ce reportage de nos confrères
de tvr sur place à rennes une page
facebook pour ne pas rentrer seul le
soir c'est l'initiative citoyenne
rennais ce qu'a lancé adélaïde où les
munier début septembre
en deux mois c'est fou même pour les
femmes et sa jumelle mixer fois que
forum compte près de 4000 membres
j'avais déjà intégré un groupe comme ça
il ya quelques mois qui a été inactif
n'avait pas de fonctionnement ni rien et
un jour j'étais sur un groupe facebook
autres avec des étudiants de rennes et
c'est un témoignage d'agression et dans
les commentaires quelqu'un a dit mais ce
serait trop cool en groupe on est tous
regroupés on s'aide et je me suis dit
mais c'est bien sûr en fait faut juste
quelqu'un qui lance le truc qui lance la
démarche ce groupe facebook qui va
bientôt également passé sur
l'application de communication discorde
est née d'une réponse urgente un besoin
urgent de sécurité des rennais au point
que ce groupe d entraide va devenir une
association où les modérateurs seront
bénévoles
voici comment ça marche quand vous
intégré le groupe il ya des publications
épinglés avec différents quartiers et
des groupes messenger sont créés en
fonction du quartier dans lequel vous
résidez où vous étudiez où vous
travaillez
si vous n'êtes pas encore intégré à un
groupe selon le quartier vous pouvez
tout simplement publié un message à
n'importe quelle heure du jour ou de la
nuit en disant voilà à telle heure je
vais faire tel trajet est ce que
quelqu'un serait le même trajet que moi
est ce que quelqu'un serait intéressé
pour qu'on y aille ensemble d'autres
dispositifs sont à venir
en partenariat avec la page instagram de
recueil de témoignages la nuit on veille
des bus pédestre avec les bénévoles
modérateur vont être mis en place la
nuit plusieurs fois par mois
place à présent à l'économie des
territoires dans son jt avec vos michel
picaud bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
nous partons pour la guadeloupe et pour
la martinique
nous partons à la rencontre d'une pme
elles s'appellent cas d'alice oui
bonjour je vous emmène en martinique et
en guadeloupe qui exportent en europe
chaque année à peu près 270 mille tonnes
de bananes il faut dire qu'en métropole
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
nous avons beaucoup mangé de bananes les
ventes ont progressé de 25% ses bananes
sont parfaites lorsque vous les achetez
mais il ya aussi des baleines moche 40
mille tonnes par an de bananes avant
table et c'est là que l'entreprise cas
d'alice a eu l'idée géniale de lancer
une marque de produits cosmétiques
utilisant les principes actifs de la
banane écouter charles et bio elle est
la présidente et fondatrice de canalys
on est une société qui a un fort impact
impact environnemental et sociétal
on recycle des déchets agricoles donc
les bananes moche moi je les appelle les
matches et les célibataires cette banque
personne ne veut qu'ils sont écartés de
la consommation on les récupère on fait
des recherches depuis maintenant presque
neuf ans on a déposé trois brevets qu'on
est à notre deuxième thèse en biochimie
et on extrait des principes actifs issus
ces déchets pour des formules et après
dandysme un cosmétique
aujourd'hui l'entreprise veut créer son
usine aux antilles et donc créer des
emplois là bas pour terminer saviez vous
qu'il y a des bananes jaunes vertes et
roses que le bananier n'est pas un arbre
mais une herbe géante que les dinosaures
ont connu et au delà des fruits tout est
bon dans le bananier les feuilles par
exemple directement impliqué sur les
plaies elles ont une action anti
biotiques et cicatrisantes
merci michel picaud vous retrouve dans
une prochaine édition du grand jt des
territoires pour nous parler de
l'économie des entreprises des
territoires retour dans l'hexagone
maintenant plus précisément dans les
yvelines où une sécheresse frappe une
véritable situation de crise pour le
département face à ce manque d'eau la
préfecture a pris des mesures d'urgence
et demande à toute la population d'être
économes en matière de l'usaj de l'eau
les détails avec les équipes de tv 78
sur place à versailles l'office national
des forêts observe de nombreux
changements sur les arbres depuis cinq
ans en cause la sécheresse
ce manque d'eau de façon récurrente plus
la canicule on a des épisodes
caniculaires de plus en plus fréquent en
ile-de-france fait que les arbres n'ont
pas accès à la ressource d'eau et en
plus de ça on un deuxième système d'
alerte c'est à dire qu'ils vont arrêter
de transpirer pour éviter de perdre de
l'eau par leurs feuilles
conséquence directe la chute des
feuilles sur le sommet des arbres et
sans feuilles l'arbre ne peut pas
croître et fabriquer sa sève tout
doucement l'art va mourir donc si ça
serait peut être régulièrement un sujet
sain un arbre s'en va pouvoir accepter
une année voilà c'est une année de
disette entre guillemets mais si ça se
reproduit chaque année il va pas pouvoir
grandir il va pas pouvoir s'alimenter et
donc la phase terminale
c'est malheureusement la mort du sujet
la situation inquiète les forestiers il
observe les arbres et tente de chiffrer
le pourcentage d'arbres dépérissants et
leur évolution
donc seules les feuilles basses on voit
ici là sont ouvertes sont encore verte
pour certaines ont commencé voilà
commencé à dépérir ça commence tout
doucement et puis ensuite la feuille est
complètement marre ont ensuite c'est le
rameau donc quand on monte en haut on se
rend compte qu'on a de moins en moins de
feuilles et puis des rameaux
complètement sec c'est à dire que cet
individu là et condamné est dans sa
phase descendante et l'année prochaine y
aura plus du tout ça il sera
complètement mort et les dernières cuit
ne suffisent pas parce qu'elle arrive au
début du repos végétatif
il faudrait qu'il pleuve au printemps
pour que la situation s'améliore
à présent nous partons à bordeaux comme
je vous le disais dans les titres grâce
aux équipes de tv7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest
là bas les vieilles voitures diesel ou
essence sont transformés en voiture
électrique
cela s'appelle le retrofit regardez ce
reportage des équipes de tv7 sur place
cette porsche 911 sc de 1982 se
déplacent accélère quasiment sans faire
de bruit
elle a été rétrocédée tous les éléments
du moteur thermique de ces voitures de
sport ont été changés pour la
transformer en véhicules électriques
batteries moteurs électroniques ont
remplacé carburateur réservoir et autres
pots d'échappement cette porsche
retrofit et affichent même des
performances de vitesse et
d'accélération supérieur au modèle
d'origine
même si son autonomie ne dépasse pas les
250 km emmanuel son propriétaire est un
collectionneur de porsche ingénieur de
formation il s'est lancé le défi
technologique de transformer cette 911
en voiture électrique avoir une voiture
comme ça qu'il soit convertir à
l'électrique
ça veut dire qu'on peut utiliser tous
les jours et du coup c'est ça devient un
autre usage une autre manière d'utiliser
la voiture et ça lui donne effectivement
une deuxième vie et pour donner cette
deuxième vie aux voitures de collection
il faut faire entrer de la haute
technologie dans un véhicule qui n'a pas
été conçu pour l'accueillir tout en
préservant ses caractéristiques
d'accélération de comportement sur la
route c'est tous les défis du rétrofit à
la transformation de sa porsche 911
emmanuel a été aidé par l'entreprise
rétro futur l'un des opérateurs français
spécialisés dans ces reconversions
cette société vient de s'installer sur
bordeaux alors que ce type de
transformation est monnaie courante dans
certains pays comme aux états unis ou en
angleterre par exemple la france vient
juste de la légaliser il s'agit
maintenant pour ces professionnels du
rétrofit d'homologuer avec les autorités
leur système de transformation un
changement relativement artisanale pour
le moment mais qui doit ce semi
industrialisés pour être viable à
l'avenir
c'est vraiment très important parce
qu'en fait c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de dupliquer de surtout
d'avoir une garantie pendant toute la
durée du véhicule et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
était vraiment aux balbutiements du
rétrofit le retrofit à l'étranger c'est
parfois
bidouillage un peu de luxe en france ça
sera de ça sera vraiment de la haute
technologie dans un vieil écran ces
homologations sont indispensables pour
que le retrofit se développe en france
elle devrait être acté d'ici quelques
mois le gouvernement vient d'ailleurs de
créer une prime de 5000 euros pour
transformer d'anciens véhicules
thermiques en électrique cette mutation
peut coûter entre 15000 et 45000 euros
en fonction du type de modèle de voiture
l'autonomie du véhicule peut varier
entre 160 et 300 km par jour
la société rétro futur qui vient donc de
s'installer sur bordeaux a déjà reçu une
centaine de précommandes de
transformation ses premiers véhicules
retrofit et seront livrés durant l'été
2021 voilà merci de votre fidélité
merci d'avoir suivi cette édition du
grand jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
de télévision locales et régionales et
sur tv5 monde
à très bientôt roi
[Musique]